como se elige a un presidente en
colombia hay reelección en este país
pues andrés en colombia la constitución
ordena que el ves el presidente y su
vicepresidente sean escogidos en
elecciones separadas de las de congreso
y las autoridades locales gana quien
logre la mitad más uno de los votos y
cuando ningún candidato lo consigue como
en esta ocasión los dos primeros pasan a
una segunda vuelta al cabo de tres
semanas este año la primera vuelta se
llevó a cabo el 29 de mayo y hoy se
sabrá si será gustavo petro o rodolfo
hernández el presidente de colombia el
periodo presidencial en este país es de
4 años y para responder a su pregunta el
presidente no puede ser reelegido desde
la constitución de 1991 sólo dos
presidentes han sido reelegidos álvaro
uribe en 2006 quien introdujo la red la
reelección en su favor y juan manuel
santos en 2014 quien en ese segundo
período en 2015 precisamente se abolió
esa figura una particularidad colombiana
es que si el voto en blanco es
mayoritario en la primera vuelta de las
elecciones unipersonales como las de
presidente
deben repetirse con candidatos
completamente distintos andrés con paolo
hablemos ahora de los poderes del
presidente que tanto poder tiene el
mandatario en una república
presidencialista como es colombia pues
como en otros países con regímenes
similares el presidente en colombia
tiene amplios poderes y no ocurre como
en los estados parlamentarios en los que
el legislativo tiene más prerrogativas
aunque la constitución de 1991 que
reemplazó a la de 1886 introdujo algunos
contrapesos la realidad andrés es que en
colombia el presidente es jefe de estado
jefe de gobierno y autoridad
administrativa suprema además de
encabezar las fuerzas armadas nombrar a
gran parte de los cargos de la rama
ejecutiva embajadores y muchos otros
altos funcionarios dirigen la diplomacia
y tiene la facultad de decidir cuál será
la relación de su país con otros estados
también tiene la facultad de decretar
estados de excepción como el de guerra
el de conmoción interior para enfrentar
crisis de orden público y estados de
emergencia que pueden ser económica
durante los cuales pueden legislar por
decreto así como lo hizo el presidente
iván duque ante la pandemia del cob y 19
las leyes por ejemplo no se promulgan
sin su firma y puede expedir decretos y
resoluciones también tiene potestades
presupuestales y de definir el llamado
plan de desarrollo que marca
definitivamente las líneas gruesas de
inversión en este cuatrenio del
presidente el mandatario también tiene
pues una gran influencia en la
estrategia del estado y todo esto le da
al presidente en colombia un gran poder
de influencia sobre el congreso con la
adjudicación de partidarias
presupuestarias o el nombramiento de
función de funcionarios a muchos niveles
apadrinados por congresistas cercanos
una práctica que usted y yo conocemos
muy bien acá en colombia como la
mermelada que es un poderoso instrumento
para influir en el legislativo de este
país como lo como hacerlo decía colombia
es una república presidencialista aunque
con la llegada de la constitución de
1991 el país empezó a combinar algunos
rasgos parlamentarios
entonces el congreso supone cierto
contrapeso para el mandatario no es así
sin duda andrés además de legislar en el
congreso también hace control político y
puede llegar a ser el mayor contrapeso
para el presidente pues puede no aprobar
proyectos de ley del ejecutivo si así lo
desea tal como le sucedió al saliente
presidente iván duque con su primer
intento de una reforma tributaria el año
pasado o cuando intentó modificar el
acuerdo de paz con la guerrilla de las
farc iniciativas que no prosperaron en
el congreso para el jefe de estado
entonces con todos sus poderes es de
suma importancia tener una coalición
mayoritaria en el congreso que apruebe
sus proyectos sin opresión es bueno con
pablo pero aparte del congreso hay otros
organismos que también pueden ponerle
freno al presidente cuando éste proponga
cosas que estén por fuera de su poder
cuáles son estos organismos así es y a
veces incluso tener una buena bancada
como respaldo en el congreso no es
suficiente ese es el caso de la corte
constitucional encargada de determinar
si las leyes aprobadas no violan la
constitución por ejemplo el entonces
presidente álvaro uribe logró hacer
aprobar su segunda reelección en el
congreso y la corte la revirtió en 2010
escuchemos
acató y respeto la sentencia de la
honorable corte constitucional mediante
la cual declara inexequible la ley que
convocaba a un referendo de reelección
presidencial el estado de derecho exige
que todos los ciudadanos nos sometamos a
la ley
pero especialmente el gobernante
que el gobernante de ejemplo en aquello
de observar la ley
pero pablo un presidente con amplios
poderes pero también con contrapesos a
los que la larga lista de mandatarios de
colombia se han enfrentado así es andrés
y es que colombia ha tenido 118
presidentes elegidos por voto popular 4
fueron reelegidos 2 murieron en el poder
uno ganó el único premio nobel de paz
que tiene el país y lamentablemente no
ha habido ninguna presidenta mujer en
este país sudamericano pues bien ese es
entonces el régimen presidencialista
colombiano muchas gracias por todo lo
por el contexto la situación hoy que se
elige presidente aquí en colombia muchas
gracias andrés